est-ce que j'ai eu la pire idée de ma
vie en filmant un mariage avec l'arrêt
de komodo je vais vous montrer des
images je vais vous en parler je vous
expliquer tout ce que j'ai amené et
comment j'ai fait pour quoi je les fais
mais ça ce sera bien entendu après
l'intro et salue légendaire à l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mme encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver ça faisait un petit moment
qu'on s'était pas vu ben normal dans ce
l'était on prend un peu le temps voilà
mais aujourd'hui j'avais quelque chose à
vous raconter à propos d'une vidéo que
j'ai tourné récemment
et d'ailleurs si vous arrivez sur cette
chaîne pour la première fois est bien
ici on parle de comment faire des vidéos
des belles vidéos je suis françois je
suis friand ce jeu suit vidéaste et je
vis de la vidéo alors comme je vous le
disais dans l'intro je suis parti sur un
délire totalement overkill de filmer un
mariage avec la red komodo la raid
commando si vous la connaissez pas j'ai
fait un test qui s'affiche quelque part
par ici c'est une caméra rennes une
caméra de signer et c'est un workflow
qui est très différent des mirrorless
comme les et 6 2 que j'utilise
d'habitude pour les mariages je suis dit
voilà on va voir les choses en grand on
va faire un truc de ouf cinématiques et
puis que tout ça avec la reine sur un
mariage et je vous en ai parlé plusieurs
fois sur un stade vous m'avez posé plein
de questions donc j'ai un petit peu
regrouper toutes ces questions là pour
essayer d'y répondre au maximum sur le
pourquoi du comment sur le matos utilisé
exactement le ring que j'avais pourquoi
j'ai utilisé tel ou tel truc
le résultat est surtout l'idée de cette
vidéo c'est de répondre à la question
est ce que ça valait le coup est-ce que
c'était intéressant est ce qu'il
faudrait que vous vous équipiers avec
une red komodo par exemple une caméra de
signer pour faire du film de mariage
c'est une question qui se pose est à
laquelle je vais répondre dans cette
vidéo
et puis pour le jeu je vais vous
demander de répondre ici à une question
à laquelle je vais répondre un peu plus
tard à votre avis quel était le poids
global des fichiers que j'ai filmé sur
ma journée de mariage
voilà juste eu juste mais qu'est ce que
vous pensez maintenant au niveau du
poids des fichiers et je donnerai la
réponse un petit peu plus tard dans la
vidéo et vous n'êtes pas prêt alors la
première chose dont on va parler ici
c'est le ring et ses terres les
accessoires que j'ai ajouté sur la
caméra le poids l'ergonomie est ce que à
la fin de la journée j'étais
complètement
éclatée et est ce que j'avais plus bras
ou plutôt on en parle tout de suite
alors j'ai utilisé cette config ici j'ai
donc le moniteur small hd une poignée la
cage tilt à les battre il a comme oddo
ici une belle blake est un petit polo
focus pour le moment où j'utilisais le
focus manuel ça on en parlera après le
sigma 18,35 la plupart du temps et un
petit filtre alors j'avais le black
promised à ce moment-là et un filtre end
et free well dessus ou là c'est un autre
puisque le pad promis stylet sur la
caméra ici et donc la bête ça s'apaise
un petit peu son poids là comme ça à vue
de pif je dirais qu'il doit y avoir à
les 1 4 kg on va dire batterie plus
objectif le boîtier plus le moniteur
plus voilà la batterie du moniteur etc
etc alors le truc c'est que
effectivement c ur ça s'appelle sont
tournés avec cette poignée ici j'ai pas
du tout senti en fait le poids dans la
journée au final j'ai même eu moins mal
au dos et mal au bras que quand
j'utilise mes boîtiers reflex mono et 6
2 par exemple
j'ai des positions qui font qu'au bout
d'un moment j'ai le dos qui fatigue
énormément au bout d'une journée de
mariage chose que je n'ai pas ressenti
ici avec la common law il ya aussi le
fait qu on la tient un petit peu
différemment par exemple vu comment elle
est fichue
très souvent je les pose et contre mon
torse je la soutiens ici avec une main
et en dessous avec l'autre main ce qui
fait que il ya quand même beaucoup moins
de fatigue à la tenir même si elle est
beaucoup plus lourde bon c'est pas non
plus un truc facile je vais pas vous
dire que j'ai rien senti et que j'ai pas
eu mal mais au final l'ergonomie était
plutôt pas mal en tout cas le poids n'a
pas été un handicap sur cette journée là
ce que j'ai fait aussi parce que la
caméra n'est pas stabilisée ça on en
parlera un petit peu après mais j'ai
utilisé aussi par moments un monopole ce
qui soulage corman les bras bien entendu
puisque là pour le coup rien apporté on
a juste à se déplacer poser la caméra ça
permet de se reposer un petit peu à
certains moments j'ai aussi par moment
utilisé 1 85 mm de chez samian qu'une
optique est très sympa qui est pas très
cher et qui me permettait un petit peu
de varier mes plans même si le 18 35 est
quand même vachement de polyvalent et
puis vachement lumineux le petit 85 de
temps en temps pour changer le type de
focales c'était un petit plus c'est ça
va ajouter quelque chose de plus sympa à
mon film le deuxième point qui
centralise aussi beaucoup de question
c'est est-ce que c'était un tournage
plus difficile
vous avez vu que physiquement c'était
pas plus difficile que ce que j'utilise
d'habitude avec mes et 6 2 c'était même
par moment un petit peu plus agréable un
peu moins fatigant mais il ya plein
d'autres points qui ont fait que c'était
quand même un tournage qui était pas
évident du tout le gros changement qui a
d'ailleurs entre la komodo et les
réflexes c'est l'auto focus alors
l'autofocus vous en avait parlé dans la
vidéo dédiée mais il est très basique
c'est juste une zone qu'on va pouvoir
déplacer et sur laquelle la caméra à
faire la mise au point il n'ya pas de
suivi de sujet il n'ya pas de suivi de
l'oeil encore moins comme sur mon set 6
2 c'est pas un autofocus de ouf
alors ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
pas mal quand même utiliser l'autofocus
en mettant la zone relativement au
centre et en la déplaçant un petit peu
de temps en temps et franchement il a
marché
super bien c'est pas un truc de malade
mais pour plein de moments sur un
mariage il faut que ça aille vite on n'a
pas forcément le temps de faire la mise
au point manuelle et des choses qui se
passent très vite des moments aussi où
j'étais même en plein soleil
donc j'avais même sur mon moniteur pas
une super retour et même avec le focus
picking j'avais pas un super retour non
plus j'ai fait confiance à la ffc
souvint et franchement il m'a pas déçu
du tout bon il faut bien viser un il
faut que ce soit juste dans la bonne
zone mais franchement il a marché très
bien à d'autres moments quand j'avais un
petit peu plus le temps et quand je
voulais faire les choses bien
j'utilisais mon petit follow focus là
c'est le tilt a un qui marche très bien
aussi avec le focus picking de mon
moniteur et franchement bas la mise au
point a été assez facile à faire sa
demande plus de concentration forcément
que l'autofocus du 7 6 qui marche très
bien sur lequel je me pose vraiment pas
de questions là dessus la bon il faut
quand même faire assez attention au
niveau des réglages des codecs de la
résolution de tout ça
j'ai tout fait en six cas en raid code
donc tous mes fichiers sont en gros
c'était tout l'intérêt de la chose ça on
va parler un petit peu après j'ai shooté
rica ratio 2,40 tout simplement parce
que bon déjà ça me donne l'aspect
cinémascope qui est assez plaisant à
l'oeil mais aussi ça me donne la
possibilité d'avoir des ralentis en 50
images par seconde même en six cas donc
j'ai pu avoir des ralentis
sans avoir à croquer dans le capteur ce
qui est un des petits défauts de la raid
commando
j'ai aussi essayé de filmer pas mal en
25 images par seconde aussi pour
économiser un petit peu le poids sur la
carte mémoire qui se sont assez vite
remplie parlé un petit peu après et j'ai
aussi utilisé le rôle moindre définit
encore une fois pour économiser un petit
peu d espaces mais ça reste quand même
du 16 bits ça reste quand même de la
folie
même le taux de compression plus fort
durée de code ça reste quand même un
truc de malade un niveau stabilisation
je ne vais pas monté sur une guibole
pour ça j'ai utilisé mon set 6 2 avec du
progrès euros pour faire quelques plein
de kimball pas beaucoup parce que je
suis pas hyper fan de ce type de plan
mais il en fallait quelques-uns la
stabilisation s'est fait à la main comme
je vous disais un le fait de pouvoir le
caler contre le torse et de pouvoir la
tenir par au dessus ça permet de
stabiliser plutôt bien et puis on a le
global shooter dollar est comme oddo qui
permet de faire une super stabilisation
en post-production et au delà ça un truc
que je dis souvent c'est vous moi j'aime
bien quand ça bouge un petit peu quand
sa vie quand la caméra on la sent un
petit peu bougé dans les mains du
caméraman dans les films et dans les
films que je fais aussi parce que je
trouve que voilà ça amène de la vie ça
arrange le clip vivent donc tout ce qui
est trop stabiliser trop saoul ou c'est
tout c'est une histoire de goût je suis
pas hyper fan non plus donc ça tombait
très bien pour ce qui est de l'autonomie
la common law fonctionne avec des
batteries comme ça qui sont des
batteries cannon là en l'occurrence
c'est des génériques parce que les
batteries cannon sont très chers il y en
a deux qui permet de changer en fait les
batteries sans éteindre la caméra en
enlevant une quand elle est vite et de
la remplacer par une qui est chargé ce
qui est plutôt pratique parce que
éteindre la caméra avec la komodo c'est
plutôt relou puisque le boutis mais à
peu près 30 secondes le tout sur un
mariage c'est pas fou fou ce qui fait
qu'en fait je ne n'ai quasiment jamais
éteinte sauf vraiment quand il y avait
des grosses pause où je savais ce qui se
passait rien
je l'étais niais comme ça et puis après
je la redémarrer mais elle est restée
allumée pratiquement toute la journée
aucune surchauffe
c'est fait pour ya pas de souci
là-dessus c'est fait pour tourner
longtemps n'y a pas de limitation de
durée enfin là dessus il n'y a pas eu de
problème j'avais quand même un chargeur
avec des batteries et dès que j'avais
des batteries qui était claquée je les
mettais à charge et ce qui me permettait
d'avoir un espèce de roulement de
batterie
les deux batteries sur la komodo je les
laissais à peu près 2 3 heures donc ce
qui est plutôt pas mal sachant que les
autres chargés pendant que j'utilisais
celle-ci franchement aucun problème
niveau autonomie j'ai pas eu de sueurs
froides pour savoir si j'allais pouvoir
finir la journée
elle a commencé tôt et elle a fini tard
mais il ya eu aucun souci là-dessus
parfum la question est-ce que c'est run
and gun en termes de réglages en termes
de shoot et c'est ben ça s'utilise
différemment d'un réflexe parce que bon
on va pas pouvoir allait rentrer dans
les réglages aussi rapidement avec tous
les boutons qu'on a sur un reflex mais
une fois qu'on a pigé le truc une fois
qu'on a fait ces réglages qu'on a un
filtre end et surtout parce que là pour
le coup beaucoup des réglages moi je les
faisais avec le filtre ou avec
l'ouverture le filtre ne permettait
d'avoir une action rapide sur mon
exposition donc ça c'était quand même
plutôt cool c'était donc plutôt run and
gun franchement j'ai pas trop de souci à
me faire là dessus le black shading qui
est donc la calibration des noirs sur
les caméras red qui est la grosse
angoisse là dessus que j'avais c'est à
dire que pour que le capteur soit dans
des conditions optimales il faut
calibrer les noix en fonction de la
température et ça je me disais ça va
être galère si je dois le faire quatre
ou cinq fois dans la journée parce que
ça prend environ une minute
donc c'est quand même assez long au
final j'ai eu à le faire une fois parce
que le matin il faisait assez frais et
l'après midi il a fait très chaud doc a
eu un moment où j'ai eu le témoin ici du
black shading qui s'est mis au lieu
d'être en verre en orange j'ai fait mon
blog shading
j'ai pas eu à leur faire par la suite ça
a été une grosse problématique même si
comme je l'avais en tête je surveillais
le voyant assez régulièrement on en
arrive au poids des fichiers et à la
postproduction est-ce que c'était lourd
à gérer est ce que c'est elle ou en
termes de poids d'ailleurs j'espère que
vous avez mis votre estimation dans les
commentaires je voudrais réponse tout de
suite
quel était le poids des fichiers le
poids global de tout ce que j'ai filmé
avec la red
dans cette journée là et bien il y en
avait pour roulements de tambour
intérêts et demi voilà s'apaisant cesser
ces gaillards effectivement c'est dur ou
dans six cas en 25 ou 50 fps donc
effectivement c'est très très gros
j'avais deux cartes s'efface 2.0 de 500
go giga il a fallu que j'ai envie de une
le midi à la pause pour pouvoir être sûr
après d'avoir assez de place j'ai quand
même dû investir dans un ssd de 2 tera
externe pour pouvoir monter mon fils ça
c'est le truc relou le poids des
fichiers c'est le truc mais gare au loup
par contre pour ce qui est de la
postproduction du des rushes du montage
de l'étalonnage là ça a été un bonheur
total faut savoir que j'ai dit est ce
film de 10 minutes
ainsi qu'à étalonner tout ça tout ralala
machin sur mon mac mini et main d'entrée
de gamme un mac à 800 balles avec 8
gigas de ram et 256 go de disque dur
voilà et il n'a pas bronché je n'ai pas
fait de proxy je n'ai pas fait de médias
optimiser tout était hyper hyper hyper
smooth franchement là dessus le codec
raid c'est un régal le workflow a été
exactement le même que d'habitude si ce
n'est pour l'étalonnage et la correction
colorimétrique
ouh là là là c'était un truc de malade
qui m'a pris plus de temps mais qui m'a
permis d'aller aussi beaucoup loin le
truc hyper cool avec ses fichiers raw
raid c'est qu'on peut gérer les
métadatas postproduction et ça c'est
assez incroyable sur le tournage je me
prenait pas la tête avec les iso avec la
balance des blancs je check est juste
mon histogramme et mes outils
d'exposition pour voir si mon image et
est bien exposé tout le reste après ça
se fait en post prod
ça c'était vraiment très très cool la
possibilité de gérer mais iso en
post-production ça m'a permis de
retravailler mon exposition à chaque
fois sans avoir besoin de rentrer dans
des réglages ou deux mètres en quelques
et ça c'est une pure dinguerie
j'ai fait un petit peu de correction sur
certains plans mais
assez peu au final et c'est ça qui est
génial c'est que le workflow
d'étalonnage était hyper rapide sur mes
plans je corrigeais un petit peu
métadatas ensuite tout simplement une
lutte de conversion pour passer du log
raid a duré qu 709 et enfin une lutte de
look de mon petit pack de lutte que vous
pouvez trouver en descriptions aqua 30%
maxi parce que les couleurs sont déjà ou
enfin on est sur du 16 bits c'est juste
incroyable et il n'ya pas besoin en fait
de faire beaucoup de d'efforts sur la
colorimétrie puisque la couleur sayan ce
raid est déjà ou grosso modo ça c'est
limiter à ça alors ça prend un peu de
temps parce que il faut corriger les
métadatas pour faire en sorte que les
plans soient bien exposé que ça match
des fois la balance des blancs elle
était un petit peu dans les choux donc
il faut le récupérer mais en fait c'est
pas une correction en fait c'est un
choix on choisit créé balance des blancs
posteriori en gros si mes scop de la
caméra me disent que l'exposition est
bonne
l'exposition une bonne chute juste pas à
m'occuper de quoi que ce soit d'autre si
ce n'est du cadrage et de la mise au
point et ça vraiment c'est le truc que
j'ai trouvé incroyable avec cette caméra
est le truc pour lequel bas on peut se
dire que bon un terrain ennemi ok ça
fait beaucoup ça va être chiant pour le
stockage mais la couleur sainz le 16
bits juste
donc est ce que ça valait vraiment le
coup est ce que je leur ferai est ce que
c'est quelque chose que je conseille je
vais vous donner la réponse à cette
question
mais juste avant je vous rappelle que si
le film le mariage c'est quelque chose
qui vous intéresse mais j'ai une
formation sur une amie qui est dans la
description qui est en ce moment en
promo à 30% et j'en profite tant qu on y
est pour aussi mettre tout le reste de
ce que je propose en promo à 30% que ce
soit la formation montage avec final cut
toujours sur le déni pareil -30%
l'élu que les préceptes lightroom tout
est dans la description promo en ce
moment allez-y c'est cadeau ça fait
plaisir
on revient donc à nos moutons pour
pouvoir vous dire si c'était la pire
idée que j'ai jamais eu ou si c'était la
meilleure idée que j'ai jamais eu
je vais vous faire les plus et les moins
et en tirer une conclusion à la fin
alors dans l'est - je vois plusieurs
choses la concentration extrême beaucoup
plus de concentration avec la red
nécessaire plutôt qu'avec mon set 6 2
oula vraiment j'ai fait un mariage le
week-end dernier avec les et 6 2 ça se
fait tout seul en fait c'est vraiment
très très très facile d'utilisation là
c'est pas que c'est plus difficile mais
que ça nécessite beaucoup plus de
concentration
il faut avoir l'oeil sur les scop il
faut avoir l'oeil
sur la mise au point il faut avoir
l'oeil sur beaucoup de choses et ça
fatigue un peu plus nerveusement on va
dire c'est plus fatigant
intellectuellement que d'utiliser un
mirrorless l'autre gros moins que je
vois et je le disais juste avant c'est
le poids des fichiers
clairement je vais devoir acheter un
disque dur systématiquement à chaque
fois que je fais un truc comme ça pour
pouvoir archiver parce que même mon raid
il va être saturé au bout de trois ou
quatre mariages est clairement donc ça
c'est c'est le point négatif c'est le
compromis à faire pour avoir toutes ses
qualités de la l'autre point négatif que
je vois c'est que sur un game boy c'est
quand même pas évident un chat encore en
train de travailler dessus je pense
qu'avec le zune crime 3 s je vais
arriver à l'équilibré correctement et à
faire quelque chose mais là aussi le
poids va être indécent c'est pas évident
de la poser sur un game boy à moins
d'avoir un tout petit optique des toutes
petites batteries
je vais faire des tests encore dessus
mais quand même un petit peu galère il
ya aussi le fait que bath est
indispensable d'avoir un rigueur on va
pas utiliser la caméra tout seul ah
c'est impossible l'écran est trop petit
il faut au moins des poignets il faut le
follow focus il faut un moniteur il faut
des batteries il faut plein de choses
pour qu'elles soient utilisables à son
plein potentiel et le côté compact il y
pas vraiment là enfin il ya les
investissements que ça représente là en
gros le ring il y en a pour dix mille
balles donc si c'est juste pour faire du
mariage
clairement je le recommande pas et il a
acheté une raide pour faire du mariage
c'est pas du tout du tout rentable c'est
pas du tout une bonne idée maintenant
moi j'ai une raide je m'en sers pour
plein de choses pourquoi ne pas
l'utiliser pour du mariage ça rien ne
l'interdît en fait il n'y a pas de souci
et je vous parle même pas des cartes
mémoires à 500 balles la carte de 500
giga quand j'avais mes deux cartes dans
la main je me disais géant smic dans la
main quoi c'est pas forcément le
meilleur investissement pour faire du
mariage uniquement et le dernier point
négatif c'est que évidemment ça
s'adresse à une clientèle de
connaisseurs
la plupart des mariés vous leur dites je
viens je filme avec une red ouais ok
bien cool c'est une caméra c'est quoi
c'est voilà ils en ont rien à faire ils
savent même pas ce que c'est la plupart
maintenant voir les plus de
l'utilisation de cette caméra pour un
mariage a déjà le rang du ciné
pour le coup c'est incomparable avec
tout ce que j'ai pu faire avant avec
énormément de choses que j'ai pu voir en
termes de films là on a vraiment un
rendu caméra on a vraiment un look film
n'y a pas à bidouiller pour donner un
look un petit peu machin tout ça si ce
n'est le black premier ce que j'ai
rajouté pour casser un petit peu la
netteté du sigma 18 35 mais clairement
la wah wah
mais marié quand ils ont vu ça il était
clairement ça l'a fait ensuite il ya ce
que je disais la gestion de métadatas en
post prod c'est tellement beau tellement
agréable et tellement pratique c'est
trop bien les facilités d'étalonnage
parce que ça va au final plus vite c'est
plus facile avec un rendu que je trouve
meilleur que avec mes hybride il ya
aussi le fait que ça a un look de
caméras et qu'on arrête de me rendre
pour un photographe parce que ben oui
oui c'est un appareil photo la plupart
du temps que j'utilise pour faire mes
films et donc les gens se met en pause
et là je leur dis non non mais ne posez
pas je filme en fait et élèves regardent
1 pourquoi il dit ça il a un appareil
photo dans la main qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que je fais donc ça évite ce
genre de moments un peu gênant là on
voit bien que c'est une caméra et enfin
le dernier point que positif que je
trouve très très très intéressant c'est
le dernier point négatif que j'ai cité
juste avant c'est à dire que ça
s'adresse à une clientèle de
connaisseurs et alors ça peut être un
point négatif parce que beaucoup de gens
ne vont pas se rendre compte et ne vont
pas voir la plus value de ce type de
caméra mais il ya des gens et ça ça
m'intéresse des gens qui sont des
connaisseurs qui ont le goût de l'image
et qui vont être sensible au fait que la
vidéo sera tourné avec une red et ça
m'intéresse de travailler avec ces gens
là parce que tout simplement c'est des
gens qui vont avoir le même appétit pour
la vidéo et pour la belle image que moi
donc on va pouvoir parler on va pouvoir
faire des choses sympas ce qui s'est
produit avec les mariés dont j'ai fait
le mariage avec la red des jambes
adorable sensible à l'image et avec
beaucoup de goût avec qui j'ai beaucoup
échangé avec qui on a beaucoup beaucoup
partagé de choses et discuter ce qui a
donné lieu à un film qui vraiment à mon
sens c'était
si qui vont voir même un des meilleurs
que j'ai pu sortir ces dernières années
si ce n'est peut-être le meilleur toi
j'en suis très content et donc la
réponse finale
à la question est-ce que c'était ma
paire idées ou est-ce que c'était une
bonne idée
eh bien je pense que dans ce cas là pour
ce mariage là c'était une très bonne
idée
je vais continuer à faire la plupart de
mariage avec le betis 2 parce que ça
suffit amplement et parce que je les
maîtrise et parce que c'est des mariages
qui vont se prêter plus un boîtier
hybride il ya peu de mariages qui vont
se prêter à un shooting à la red
mais c'est quelque chose que je vais
proposer maintenant parce que dans
certains cas c'est vraiment vraiment un
grand grand kiff
eh bien c'était pour cette fois là à mon
sens une très bonne idée
d'ailleurs une autre très bonne idée que
vous pourriez avoir c'est de mettre le
coup de blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo de vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait d'aller voir une
autre vidéo là ici parce que j'ai fait
une web série l'a dernièrement qui va
vous plaire avec l'arrêt des tours ou
attendant moi je vous dis les amis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo show